[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i took your heart
[Music]
i did things to your only lovers
these popes and preachers would tell me
i did wrong but hey
you later
[Music]
stranger still
don't know my name
you still don't know my name
[Applause]
but you
[Music]
wish you wish you'd come over
miss you kiss you and make believe
[Music]
i'm dreaming of all of the possibilities
kissing all over your body
i still don't know
[Applause]
but you still don't know
[Music]
feel the
[Music]
just a lifetime cause it's been a long
day
[Music]
camera flash don't forget your hashtag
rockset white stacks
you're a dead man and better rid the
deck
[Applause]
[Music]
detective
[Music]
[Music]
so stupid
[Music]
i smoke something
[Music]
[Music]
but i'm asleep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm taking it off
[Music]
i'm doing it all
[Music]
i'm doing
[Music]
taking it off
[Music]
no food in the kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
just for your love yeah
if it makes me
i'm taking it i'm taking it off
[Music]
when it all comes down
when i go disappear
into that good night
i'm taking it off for a song
[Music]
in
hey
you